hello and welcome to this video new
playing w JW from the Netherlands I get
really relatively no way to opposition
that time of day today but different it
seems whenever you play it to different
situations yes ok we play very sharp
line in the Benoni let's see what my
opponent does yeah I think here wide
usually retreats the bishop I'm going
for a direct attacking play on the
kingside directly going for the attacker
let's see how to play this Queen here
maybe for Bishop g5 ok I'm not really
familiar with this I have haven't I
never had this on the board let's say
hitter in a classical time control game
you can take on default prolia 495
just place great move here 93 I think it
is good i probably have to take here
amazing didn't spot this idea okay but
well i'm not sure how great is now that
i look at it again I have 95 and my
Center is somewhat stabilized now does
he want to see going to take koji 80
[Music]
Bishop g5 this probably have six coming
I wouldn't have Bishop f4 is not so bad
okay how to do this you will take on g6
with the rook the things I don't have
anything great here always love that if
the Samsung lagu g6 turns out to work
somehow edit it seems to do OOP g6 queen
of two was my idea threatening look at
eight at least and if the bishop is sick
so i can take b7
[Music]
28 yeah whatever if I don't take this
and the whole thing was completely
pointless okay probably trying to play
we get aid
hmm not so eating them can I am somehow
improve this night d phi he has were
covered that never will happen to f5
maybe
now III is not bad it looks at all the
critical squares 94 in some cases could
be good then then you didn't really have
all that much
hold how to make some progress though
maybe just a tech parts look c6 on
something I look a six and I mean look a
seven to play with a six
no b3 does he get some counter play with
this generally i mean i have only very
small things what no then i take a lap
resign that was probably a mouse click
yeah i mean i'm clearly better they have
it there's no super clear way forward so
we have that was really a bit strange
orders so this move night tix yeah i
mean this i felt was very very nice yeah
and the engine confirms that but this is
also good so this one and yeah taken by
the computer six and now she takes is
given as good I had this vague suspicion
during the if you rank the game I can
take care of a joke g8 and tell me where
do I go with this this this oops nope
yeah and I have no good square I mean
this is just nothing they should take
one in five amazing yet here he
basically blundered g6 x 58 works em
it's amazing that this is no advantage
at all cook it as some kind of
repetition look F 6056
yeah the problem is that I get
continuously attacked and if I'm not if
I'm not circumspect i might get made in
tomorrow only here i've got control yeah
it's it's a pole and I've the better
structure so it should be a clear
advantage but what still have been some
work if you wouldn't have given me the
route ok guys thanks for watching